I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense good advice on like how to talk
about something that's difficult is you
know asking the other person okay look
if I need to bring something up with you
when is the best time to do that because
because it can be you can be offended if
they don't want to talk about it when
they do but maybe it's just not the
right space yes right like you know I'm
a morning person so if I get up and want
to address something and somebody's
half-asleep not good timing right or you
know I can address something get like
get through it
aka listen to me really quickly over
here off to the side and a group and
then it's like no that's not the time or
the place so it can also be beneficial
I've heard to like say hey so-and-so
what is the best time for us to go
through things or what's the best way or
how to address some because the timing
can be something that that's off you
know that's super valid because that
also was a part of the work that we did
like you're spot-on
Oh literally Ben would bring up for me
it's always a good time
I can go deep it like any time let's go
that was actually for you yeah for me
yeah at any time yeah what for for Ben
yeah it's not and he had she said so so
how is this and when are these
conversations coming up and kind of the
morning like I wake up and if I'm
feeling something it just comes right
out yeah and she's you're its parent I
can't help it right it just comes and so
so she you know held that space and a
spend so for you what is that and what
is what is kind of like a no no time and
he said before work before we're both
going into work like I feel that we're
in an energy of we're getting ready to
hold space for other people and yeah
totally put our intention into other
things yeah I actually navigate through
this is not before work and so and it's
that simple but I was like oh and now if
consciousness around it so when I do
feel that I still for myself I'd still
need to write down and feel what's
coming through for me but I wait to kind
of work to have a conversation with him
around it and whatever time that is a
night and I love what you said ask
and checking in yeah because even that
night when he when he's depleted maybe
that's not the right so we it's a
totally okay to carve out the last thing
you want to do if you're being
vulnerable is then be also dismissed or
not seen again on and even like right
you're like Here I am
I'm or the disc and even more disconnect
exactly because you're like holy [ __ ]
I'm gonna go there I finally got the
guts or I for or this is so important to
me I need to address it why isn't it
then we're projecting why isn't is it as
important to you as it is to me right
when it might just not be that big of a
deal er the answer might be really
simple and clear and not gonna offend
you at all so yeah to enter into that
vulnerable space and then to be rejected
basically and not seen and not heard can
be can make matters worse
so sometimes so basically it really all
comes down to these good old-fashioned
things like it's all about communication
it is okay I explained relationships
like it's like like I was saying the
other day it's like going to the doctor
and you get your clean bill of health
and you don't want to go you don't want
to go and then you finally going like oh
man I feel so much better and then all
the best thing you can do after that is
go regularly so that no matter what
happens in your life with your body if
anything comes in that needs to be fixed
your your stage one you know what I mean
like you're you catch it quickly it's
it's usually manageable it's quick it's
easy then that is like that is an easy
way to catch things and then I feel like
that's the same thing in relationships
you have to if you can catch things
early enough and stop letting them build
up and stop pushing them down until the
point where it literally just becomes
part of your personality with your
partner then you will always keep the
decks clear and you'll always feel this
energy of being on the same page like I
feel like you hear in relationships
they're like I don't know we're just out
of sync right now we're just we're just
not like we're just not on the same page
right now it's because your your energy
or vibration is off like someone is mad
someone is offended someone is sad
someone is like someone is not seen
someone someone is someone is thinking
negative thoughts and so you don't feel
like you're in sync
same page because your your
vibrationally not
[Music]